i got a debate club for y'all um i'm
polyamorous
uh been polly for a little while now and
i'm just kind of loving it
uh getting to openly date whoever i want
be in relationships maybe not be in
relationships you know just
live and how i want to live um but the
debate club would be polyamory
slash non-monogamy versus monogamy
so polyamorous that means you're into
guys girls whatever
um it's more so just that you're not
monogamous in your relationships
oh thank you for clarifying that yeah
thank you
thank you yeah um
i think it's i think it's i mean
sounds lonely it sounds
oh quite the opposite brandon oh really
thank you
yeah yeah quite the opposite brendan i
mean you get to to be with as many
people as
as you want to be with that's kind of
yeah bro
there it's about love man it's about
like the 1970s and about
being in love you freak
is it a popular trend i feel like it is
especially with the younger crowd
um yeah i'd say it's definitely more
popular with younger
people than older people now what's the
downside to being polyamorous
you have to give us one good question
actually yeah that is a good question
the only thing i can think of is that a
lot of people don't really fully
understand it right so like sometimes
they'll think like
oh like i'm polyamorous until i find
someone that i want to be monogamous
with but that's like not
oh so you're saying once you go polly
you got to stay polly
well i mean there's a there's a saying
like my poly is not your poly so like
polly's pretty much
different for every single person that
does it like there's not really one
single definition
if you want to so what is polyamorous
when it comes to different colored
macaroons i know that
yeah i like them all daddy yeah i've
seen this guy
yeah macaroons really so what so
for for you so like right now how many
people you
are you seeing um
so i have one person that i'd consider
like a partner but then i'm dating also
a couple
and then i'm i have another
male that's like a more like friends
with benefits situation
and i have a female who's like rent a
benefit situation okay
it sounds like a lot of work though
paulie sounds like work
love is infinite but time is finite baby
yeah yeah you got to get your little
chubby [ __ ] out there brendan
you're hot today so what i want to tell
you is what i'm proud of you
and yeah you can do whatever you want
you know what i'm saying
somebody's got to keep things hot around
town and then some of us are polly in
the closet
no polly want a cracker come on out dog
pollywood community man the only thing i
like is women and that's
it if i see hey nobody believe in that
dude
you can be polly and only like women
thank you very much and that's me you
gotta share that ass with the world
oh yeah there you go i mean there's your
new [ __ ] counselor dog i like it look
i'm just happy to be alive and i'm glad
you're alive and i'm glad that you're
able to date other people i think
if you can handle it i think at some
point it just seems like
i don't want to get cornered into a
space where like
you're like you go to get drinks from
the bar or something you and you you
turn around and you got like
your boyfriend's over there and then
your husband's over there and then
you're
you know your son who you're dating also
is over there
and you don't know where to what table
to take the drinks back to yeah
you gotta buy 19 drinks you're going
broke buying a round
yeah boys i don't want to need a fan
just to date you know like that
that's the only thing that sounds a
little yeah i don't waste money on uber
plus just to get it done you know
yeah i don't want to uh yeah i think uh
i think
that's the only thing would be the um
the too much
having too much going on but if you can
handle it more power to you i can i'm
not built for that life
yeah no if you got that yeah i think if
you can get
out there and you got that shop vac
[ __ ] get it out there and do work you
feel me and no offense
but a little effective sorry but a
little hopefully you got to be true also
be careful nowadays though
that's my nickname for brendan also shot
back [ __ ] so
it is what it is i've actually never
heard that term but
it's a little offense for sure sorry
stay with the offense
i didn't check the name with him first
so i should have
um but look i think yeah you got to love
i think put as much love as you can
out there but don't just miss don't miss
out on an
opportunity to strap something good down
when you got something good
yeah strap it on yeah good good luck
though yeah
more power to you girl we support it all
right thanks
yeah good luck yeah keep ganging it and
buzzing it
yeah gang gang buzz balls buzz buzz girl
[Music]
is